in the last couple of videos we've been
slowly moving towards our goal of
figuring out the surface area of this
torus and we did it by evaluating a
surface integral in order to evaluate a
surface integral we had to take the
parameterization take its partial with
respect to s and with respect to t we
did that in the first video then we had
to take its cross product we did that in
the second video now we're ready to take
the magnitude of the cross product we
have to take the magnitude of the cross
product and then we can evaluate it
inside of a double integral and we will
have solved or we would have computed an
actual surface integral something you
see very few times in your education
career so this is this is kind of
exciting
so this was the cross product right here
now let's take the magnitude of this
thing and you might remember the
magnitude of any of any vector is kind
of a pythagorean theorem and in this
case it's going to be kind of the the
distance formula the pythagorean theorem
in three dimensions so the magnitude
this right here is the this is equal to
just as a reminder
is equal to this right here it's equal
to the partial of r cross
the partial of r with respect to s
crossed with this partial of r with
respect to t
let me
copy and paste it that is equal to that
right there
but an equal sign
these two quantities are equal now we
want to figure out the magnitude so if
we want to take the magnitude
the magnitude of this thing
so if we are interested in taking the
magnitude of that thing that's going to
be equal to well this is just a scalar
that's multiplying everything so let's
just
write the scalar out there so b
plus a
cosine of s
times the magnitude of this thing right
here and the magnitude of this thing
right here is going to be
is going to be the the sum of you can
imagine it's the square root of this
thing dotted with itself or you could
say it's the sum of the squares of each
of these terms to the one-half power so
let me write it like that so it's equal
to
let me write the
the sum of the squares so if you square
this you get a
squared
cosine
cosine squared of s
sine
squared of t that's that term
plus let me color code it that's that
term
plus i'll do the magenta plus that term
squared plus a squared cosine squared
of s cosine squared of t that's that
term and then finally i'll find and do
another color this term squared so plus
a squared
sine
squared of s it's going to be all of
this business to the one-half power
this right here
this right here is the same thing as the
magnitude of this right here this is
just a scalar that's multiplying by both
of these terms so let's see if we can do
anything interesting here if this can be
simplified in any way we have a squared
cosine squared of s we have an a squared
cosine squared of s here so let's factor
let's factor that out from both of these
terms and see what happens so we could
i'm just going to rewrite the second
part so this is going to be a squared
cosine squared of s
times
times sine
squared of t
the parentheses sine squared of t plus
cosine oh i want to do in that magenta
color not orange
plus
cosine squared of t sine squared of t
plus cosine squared of t
and then you're going to have this plus
a squared
a squared sine squared of s and of
course all of that is to
all of that is to
the
one half
power now what is this well we have sine
squared of t plus cosine squared of t
that's nice that's equal to 1 or the
most basic of trig identity so this
expression right here simplifies to
a squared cosine squared of s
plus
this over here a squared sine squared of
s and all of that to the one half power
you might immediately recognize you can
factor out an a squared this is equal to
a squared times cosine squared of s plus
sine squared
sine
squared of s and all of that to the
one-half power i'm just focusing on this
term right here i'll write this in a
second but once again cosine squared
plus sine squared of anything is going
to be equal to one as long as it's the
same anything it's equal to one so this
term is a squared to the one half power
or a square the square root of a squared
which is just going to be equal to a so
all of this all of that crazy business
right here just simplifies all of that
just simplifies to a
so this cross product here simplifies to
this
times
a which is a pretty neat and clean
simplification so let me rewrite this
so this
that
simplifies
it simplifies to
it's equal to
a times that and what's that a times b
so it's a b
a b
plus a squared cosine of s plus a
squared
cosine
of s so already we've gotten pretty far
it's nice when you do something so
beastly and eventually it gets to
something reasonably
reasonably simple and just to review
what we had to do what our mission was
several videos ago is we want to
evaluate what this thing is over the
region
from s
over the region over which the surface
is defined for so s going from 0 to 2 pi
and t going from 0 to 2 pi
over this
region so we want to integrate this over
that region so that region we're going
to have
we're going to vary s from 0 to 2 pi
so d s and then we're going to
vary t from 0 to 2 pi
dt and this is what we're evaluating
we're evaluating the magnitude of the
cross product of these two partial
derivatives of our original
parameterization so this is what we can
put in there things are getting simple
all of a sudden or simpler a b plus a
squared
cosine
of s
and what is this equal to so this is
going to be equal to
well we just take the anti-derivative of
the inside with respect to s
so the anti-derivatives let me do the
outside of our integral so we're still
going to have to deal with the 0 to 2 pi
and our dt right here
but the anti-derivative with respect to
s right here is going to be
a b is just a constant so it's going to
be a b s
plus what's the anti-derivative of
cosine of s it's sine of s so plus a
squared sine of s and we're going to
evaluate it from 0 to 2 pi 0 to 2 pi and
what is this going to be equal to
let's put our boundaries out again or
our the t integral that we're going to
have to do in a second 0 to 2 pi
dt
when you put 2 pi here you're going to
get a b
times 2 pi or 2 pi a b so you're going
to have 2 pi
a b
plus a squared sine of 2 pi sine of 2 pi
0 so there's not going to be any term
there and then minus
0 times
0 times a b which is 0 and then you're
going to have minus a squared sine of 0
which is also 0. so all of the other
terms are all zeros so that's what we're
left with it simplified nicely
so now we just have to take the
antiderivative of this with respect to t
with respect to t and this is a constant
t so this is going to be equal to take
the anti-derivative with respect to t
2 pi
a b
t
and we need to evaluate that from 0 to 2
pi which is equal to so you put 2 pi in
there you have a 2 pi for t it'll be a 2
pi times 2 pi a b or we should say 2 pi
squared times a b
minus 0 times this thing well that's
just going to be 0 so we're going to
have to write it down
so we're done this is the surface area
of the tors so this is equal to this is
exciting it just kind of snuck up on us
this is equal to
4 pi squared
a b
which is kind of a neat formula because
it it's a very neat and clean you know
it has the 2 pi which is kind of the
diameter
of a circle we're squaring it which kind
of makes sense because we're taking the
product of
you know you can kind of imagine the
product of these two circles
these two circles i'm speaking in very
abstract general terms but that kind of
feels good and then we're taking this
the product of those two radiuses
remember let me just copy this thing
down here let me actually let me copy
this thing because this is our new this
is our exciting result
let me copy this so copy
so all of this work that we did
simplified to this
which is exciting
which is exciting we now know that if
you have a torus where the radius of the
cross section is a the radius of the
cross section is a and the radius of
from the center of the torus to the
middle of the cross sections is b
that the surface area of that torus is
going to be 4 pi squared times a times b
which i think is a pretty pretty neat
outcome